hi in this video I'll talk about B cell
activation if we recall our first lesson
we can understand that B cell
development takes place in the bone
marrow inside bone marrow
there is hematopoietic input and stem
cell which give rise to lymphoid
progenitor from the lymphoid progenitor
in subsequent stage late Proby cell then
pre b-cell and match your B cell
development take place at the immature
b-cells stage the B cell has its b-cell
receptor which is membrane bound IgM now
at this particular stage immature leaves
immature b-cell decide to leave the bone
marrow and move into the bloodstream
now following the blood stream it moves
towards the peripheral lymph Argon's
such as the lymph node now the lymph
node has specific anatomical location
for T and B cells residence the B cells
reside in the follicles but they form
the germinal centers whereas the T cell
resides in the para cortex this is like
an army base or an army base camp where
for bland troopers and for the Marines
there are several army barracks
nevertheless inside the terminal center
or the follicles the P cell proliferate
and they encounter the antigens there
which is taken to them by the dendritic
cells and in response to that they would
decide to differentiate into antibody
secreting plasma cells now the B cell
activation could be of could be by two
different kind of antigens one type of
antigen is called timing-dependent
antigen and these kind of cases requires
t-cell involvement in case of B cell
activation the T cell interacts with the
B cell and the B cell has the antigen on
its surface bound to the class 2 MHC
molecule because it's a antigen
presenting cell as well
so it would select the it would display
the antigen to the T cell and the TCR
and MHC interaction would give rise to
one signal and another signal is given
by the cd4 T and cd40 ligand interaction
these two combined signal actually leads
to B cell activation in case of the th
dependent antigens in case of the th
independent antigens and we would talk
about th independent antigens in a
moment it doesn't involve the T cell
help most of the cases it can either be
activated by repetitive antigens or
sometimes it also involves both a
recognition of an antigen by the
antibody and also the the toll like
receptors the innate immune receptors so
generally the flagellum which is a part
of the bacterial flagella could be a
repetitive antigen it cross links a lot
of membrane bound M IgG and that gives
rise to the signal for B cell activation
whereas the bacterial lipopolysaccharide
LPS can also serve as an T independent
antigen and leads to B cell activation
however B cell activation is strong
stronger when it involves the T cell
help now beat a th dependent B cell
activation or th independent B cell
activation both the cases the B cell
reentered the cell cycle because
generally the immature b-cells are at g0
phase so they reenter the cell cycle at
g1 and from there they progress g1 to s
then they increase their genetic
material by DNA replication at that
stage and thereby they proliferate in
number now let us look at what happens
inside the lymph node and what are the
process of P cell activation and what
happens just after the B cell activation
what does the B cell activated b-cell
become and what is it
function so we are now at the para
cortex where the T helper cell is
helping the B cell to get activated and
it's giving the signal of activation to
the B cell and the B cell then would
either become a specific subtype of
plasma cells which would secrete
antibody and that would leave the lymph
node and go to the circulation this is
one possibility but there is also other
possibility when it would enter the beat
of follicles and then it would
proliferate making more b-cells and
eventually they would differentiate into
antibody producing plasma cells now
let's look at this process in lock more
details so inside the terminal Center
there are two regions one is a dark zone
one is the light zone and this
demarcation is based on the density of
the cells and that's how it looks like
in a H&E staining so inside the dark
zone there are so many B cells which are
proliferating and dividing these B cells
would either have very high affinity
interaction or it would have very low
affinity interaction towards an antigen
if the B cell has very low affinity
towards an antigen then it would undergo
apoptosis
but these proliferation of these B cells
in the germinal Center is aided by the
4-wheeler generate Excel follicular
dendritic cell many secrets B cell
activation factor which is a signaling
ligand of NF kappa-b family and the
receptor is NF Kappa bitter family
receptor and this signaling leads to
proliferation and maintenance of these
dividing P cells in the terminal Center
now the cells which have very low
affinity towards antigen they also gets
a chance to increase their affinity
towards the antigen if they can do that
then they would survive if their
affinity towards an antigen is rectified
then
they would eventually differentiate into
a plasma cell otherwise they would die
by apoptosis
now inside the germinal Center dark zone
the proliferating b-cells is undergoing
a process called somatic hypermutation
in the somatic hypermutation there are
several mutation in the P cell it's
taking place as a result it is creating
a b-cell receptor with high affinity or
low affinity now low affinity b-cell
receptors are not so useful for the body
because at the end of the day the lymph
node inside the lymph node they want to
create a b-cell which is highly reactive
towards an antigen and can take the
antigen with higher affinity so the
lower affinity b-cells would eventually
undergo apoptosis and they would be
eliminated whereas the high affinity
ones would eventually differentiate but
before differentiation they would
undergo a process known as class
switching now normally B cells Express
the B cell receptor which is membrane
bound IgM or sometimes IG t but the
plasma cells that they would produce
they would have a class switching in
this class switching the IgM would no
longer be expressed and now they would
express IgG type or IgA type antibody so
that leads to the diversity of responses
towards a particular antigen imagine
there are so many antigens that if that
is encountered by our body right and
each of the cases bezel has to produce
antibody against so many different type
of antigens with very precise affinity
and high interaction so and this kind of
processes are achieved by class
switching and somatic hypermutation but
in this video we are not going to talk
about that in details and I have a
separate video on that but in this video
what we learned is the process of P cell
activation which can either have an
Intel dependent or independent way and
where it happens and what is the
consequence of it and after activation
without the process what are the process
so I hope you enjoyed this video if you
like this video give it a quick thumbs
up and don't forget to Like share and
subscribe please like this video such
that I can reach a bigger audience and
it takes a lot of effort to create this
video so please take your take your time
and comment after this video thank you